l'hebdo politique bonsoir à tous je suis
ravi de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
saison de ligue 2 aux politiques tous
les dimanches sur radio sensations et
sur tv 78 nous échangerons avec un
acteur de l'actualité politique elle
sera on n'en doute pas très chargée en
cette année d'élection présidentielle
place donc tout de suite à la politique
avec mon premier invité de la saison aly
rabais candidat à la mairie de trappes
[Musique]
lecture politique
l'hebdo politique épisode de sang ali
rabais bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
candidat à la mairie de trappes et vous
avez donc commencer la politique à
poissy en 2008 où vous étiez élu
conseiller municipal sur une liste
socialiste en 2011 benoît hamon devient
porte-parole du parti socialiste et vous
son bras droit vous devenez son
directeur de campagne pour les
législatives de 2012 avant d'intégrer
ensuite ces différents cabinets
ministériels à l'éducation nationale et
à l'économie sociale et solidaire sous
la présidence de françois hollande en
2017 vous rejoignez son mouvement
générations et entre temps dans les
yvelines vous êtes devenu maire adjoint
à trappes de guy malandain anciens du
parti socialiste et ancien maire de
trappes pendant 19 ans et enfin l'année
dernière vous avez été élu maire avec 40
40 % des voix devant othman nas rookie à
lui récolté 37 18 % des voix et devant
l'ancien maire guy malandain qui à lui
réuni 22 40 % des votes
si vous êtes de nouveau candidat
aujourd'hui c'est parce que le conseil
d'état a invalidé cette élection il vous
a été reproché d'avoir distribué des
masques des colis alimentaires ou encore
des kits pédagogiques et cela sans les
avoir déclarés dans vos condor votre
compte de campagne l'écart entre vous et
votre principal concurrent othman nasri
n'étant alors que 260 et une voix
le conseil d'état a jugé que cela avait
pu altérer la sincérité du scrutin voilà
donc pourquoi les trappistes doivent
revoter et pour élire leur maire le 10
octobre les cartes ont été rebattues
pour cette élection vos deux principaux
adversaires othman nas roues et guy
malandain sont désormais liste commune
il parle d'un front républicain pour
vous barrer la route vous êtes surpris
par cette alliance entre le ps et la
droite ou est ce que vous faisiez
attendiez
elle est évidemment surprenante elle
heurte de nombreux trappistes mais je
m'y attendais je m'y attendais parce que
dès l'année dernière dès mon élection
municipale quand j'ai été élu maire par
le conseil municipal guy malandain à
voter non pas blanc non pas pour le
maire candidat ali rabais mais il a voté
au sein du conseil municipal pour la
candidature d'autres magnats seront donc
déjà à ce moment là juste après sa
défaite il a montré un certain nombre de
certaines de proximité avec othman nasri
et cette proximité se traduit
aujourd'hui par une alliance de la carpe
et du lapin parce qu'ils n'ont rien en
commun vous l'avez dit guy malandain été
longtemps un élu ps député conseil
régional conseiller départemental il a
défendu les valeurs de la gauche
historiquement il est connu d'ailleurs
est respectée pour sa attrape parce que
la ville de trappes est une ville plutôt
à gauche avec des électeurs qui lui ont
fait confiance pendant longtemps et
beaucoup me disent aujourd'hui se sentir
trahi quelque part par sa décision de
rejoindre le candidat de la droite prend
le vice-président de valérie pécresse et
considère que ça n'a pas de sens moi je
regrette qu'à 84 ans guy malandain n'ai
pas su va passer la main dès l'année
dernière il aurait dû intelligemment
passer la main je crois que ça ce serait
mieux passé l'élection en 2020 et un an
après plutôt que de tirer les
conséquences de cette forme
d'attachement excessif au pouvoir qui à
la fin l'amène à être rejetée par ses
propres électeurs il aurait mieux fait
de se retirer discrètement de la vie
politique ou en tout cas de se présenter
le cas échéant en annonçant la couleur
mais être mû comme il l'est
malheureusement en ce moment uniquement
par la rancoeur par la frustration par
une forme de haine d'ailleurs n'est pas
la haine n'est pas bonne conseillère en
politique donc il a rejoint la liste
d'hotman nasro en cinquième position et
le même othman nasri qui disait de lui
en 2014 la même chose que ce qu'il dit
de moi aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
monsieur n'à seront qualifiés guy
malandain d'hommes clientéliste qui
favoriser le communautarisme qui avait
une gestion désastreuse de la ville de
trappes il l'accusait des pires infamies
en 2014 ils font aujourd'hui front
commun contre moi donc vous voyez bien
que dans cette alliance qui une alliance
de façade de personnes qui finalement
n'ont rien en commun ce n'est pas
l'intérêt des trappistes qui est
recherché ce n'est pas l'avenir de la
ville de hop qui les mobilise c'est
avant tout la volonté de faire tomber le
maire sortant de trappes de votre côté
malgré toutes ces procédures judiciaires
et ses rebondissements vous n'avez
jamais imaginé ne pas vous représenter
ça n'avait pas de sens pour moi parce
que j'ai sollicité et obtenu la
confiance des trappistes qu'il y a un an
pour 6 ans pour un mandat complet vous
l'avez dit il parfaitement résumé ce
qu'on me reproche à travers cette
annulation de l'élection ce n'est pas
des fraudes ce n'est pas d'avoir triché
avec les élections ce n'est pas d'avoir
payé des bulletins de vote ce qu'on me
reproche c'est d'avoir distribué en
pendant le confinement c'était une
situation exceptionnelle rappelez vous
après le premier tour le deuxième tour
était suspendu on parlait même de le
reporter d'un an et moi j'ai toujours eu
la trappe des activités associatives
j'étais président d'une association qui
était très active qui fait du soutien
scolaire dans ma ville qui mobilise des
habitants autour de leur projet et des
habitants ont souhaité organiser la
fabrication et la distribution de
masques vous vous souvenez à l'époque on
en trouvait nulle part et bien des
bénévoles de mon association ont
souhaité fournir aux trappistes des
masques qu'ils fabriquaient qu'on
couzeix nous mêmes donc cette action je
les réalise et je n'ai aucun regret les
trappistes avait besoin de trade à ce
moment là et notre mobilisation et quand
je dis notre mobilisation c'est pas
l'équipe d'ali rabais c'est
l'association dont j'étais le président
et qui comptait de très nombreux
bénévoles à travers la ville beaucoup
d'ailleurs qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec
la politique et qui ne sont pas élus et
bien cette association était utile aux
trappistes mais j'aurais dû être
attentif parce qu'au moment où je
m'engageais sur cette action nous étions
dans une période floue d'entre deux
tours même si le deuxième tour devait
être repoussé d'un an d'après les
journaux ou quelques mois malgré tout
nous étions dans une période d'entre
deux tours qui aurait dû me conduire à
être vigilants quant aux actions menées
et surtout mener ces actions étaient
parfaitement légales et j'aurais dû en
demander le remboursement à l'état
plutôt que de financer avec les dons des
bénévoles donc avec le recul je le
regrette si j'avais demandé à l'état de
payer ces actions associatives il n'y
aurait pas eu d'annulation l'élection
vous voyez mais je souhaite insister sur
un point c'est que monsieur nas rouler
et les trappistes le savent très bien à
distribuer des milliers de masques à
trappes juste avant l'élection en y
apposant sa photographie et ses milliers
de masques ont été distribués payés par
le contribuable est inscrit dans ses
comptes de campagne mais partiellement
inscrit dans ses comptes de campagne
nous avons démontré que monsieur n'à
soit distribué des milliers de masques
il a déclaré que sans l'eau dans ses
comptes de campagne donc il a
sournoisement manoeuvrer sournoisement
jouer avec les règles code électoral
pour passer sous les radars il a osé me
mettre en cause sur une action
finalement qu'il a mené lui même pendant
l'entre-deux-tours et pour être complet
du côté des autres candidatures on
retrouve les candidatures de robert
nagare timone et de l'udc miserait nous
aurons l'occasion de les entendre
prochainement sur radio sensations et
vous oubliez patrick planque de lutte
ouvrière pour cette précision
l'abstention était très forte lors de
l'édition municipal de 2020 61 75 % au
second tour cela représente une réserve
de voix très conséquente est ce que ce
sera la clé selon vous cette abstention
pour cette élection absolument
habituellement malheureusement attrape
les élections ne déclenche pas les
foules nous avons à peu près 45 % de
participation aux élections municipales
de 2008 ou 2014 par exemple ça a chuté
en 2020 à 37% de mémoire au second tour
et le contexte de confinement de crise
sanitaire il ya joué pour beaucoup
partout en france la participation a
chuté d'un peu près 20 points dont 4 ap
la participation n'est
traditionnellement pas importante mais
l'enjeu pour moi effectivement c'est de
mobiliser
ma stratégie celle de mon équipe et de
la gauche réunie autour de moi c'est
d'aller chercher nos électeurs un parent
c'est de dire autres à puisqu'ils sont
concernés par ce qu'il se passe je
trouve qu'ils ne sont relativement quand
je me balade dans les rues de trappes
quand je circule et qu'on m'interpelle
j'ai je reçois beaucoup de soutien et je
sens une vraie mobilisation des
trappistes et c'est plutôt rassurant
maintenant la clé de l'élection se
jouera en effet la face à une coalition
hétéroclite d'adversaires qui n'ont rien
en commun mais qui veulent additionner
des voix c'est la participation qui
viendra jouer en notre faveur et qui
permettra à la ville de trappes de
rester une ville de gauche une ville
écologistes une ville solidaire qui
tient à ses services publics qui
cherchent à les améliorer et donc la
victoire de l'équipe que j'ai l'honneur
de mener se jouera au niveau de la
participation et au niveau de
mobilisation des trappistes et c'est ça
l'enjeu pour nous des quinze derniers
jours la campagne 2002 main était très
compliqué vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui
les conditions se sont un peu améliorées
c'est plus facile d'être au contact des
trappistes ou pas où et comment
allez-vous organiser cette campagne mais
en tout cas c'est plus agréable que le
contexte sanitaire nous permettent de
nouveau aller au contact des électeurs
l'année dernière c'était très
particulier ne pouvions pas échanger
avec les habitants donc nous nous
organisons demain samedi demain pardon
on est extrêmement sera dimanche soir
donc lire sur l'après midi nous avons
donc organisé un rassemblement festif on
a voulu aussi donner l'occasion aux gens
de sortir de chez eux de se retrouver
autour d'une candidature d'une liste
pour échanger discuter de l'avenir de la
ville de trappes mais le faire de façon
festive à pouvoir emmener avec soi ses
enfants pouvoir mélanger les personnes
âgées les enfants les adultes et
échanger sur ce que sont les
préoccupations des trappistes et donc
plusieurs centaines de trappistes se
rassemblent sent pas sanitaire puisqu'on
est en extérieur c'est aussi une façon
de discriminer personnes et j'y tiens
beaucoup pour pouvoir se réunir se
retrouver faire la fête profité d'un
pique nique et on a en a beau temps donc
c'est c'est que du bonheur et pouvoir
échanger sur le contenu notre projet sur
le bilan d un an parce que nous avons un
bilan contrairement à nos adversaires
qui n'ont que le ministère de la parole
nous nous avons réalisé beaucoup en un
an et je crois que nous allons y revenir
alors une élection aux municipales c'est
une tête de liste je vous ai longuement
présenté tout à l'heure mais c'est aussi
une liste alors comment at elle été
construite c'est la même qu'en 2020 elle
change à la marge mais effectivement on
ne change pas une équipe qui gagne
l'équipe qui a été élu l'année
précédente l'essentiel des élus
continuent à mener le combat à mes côtés
et donc seront de nouveau candidat à la
prochaine élection municipale ils
continueront la plupart d'entre eux sur
les mêmes fonctions avec les mêmes
missions à mes côtés pour servir les
trappistes il y a des éléments nouveaux
également qu'ils nous rejoignent pour
renforcer l'équipe si nous remportons
l'élection dans 15 jours nous aurons
davantage encore d'élus que l'année
dernière puisqu'il n'y a que deux listes
principales là où il y en avait 3 il y a
un an et j'ai voulu rassembler mois les
partis politiques de gauche bien sûr
puisque nous sommes une liste d'union de
la gauche mais j'ai voulu rassembler
bien au-delà des personnes qui n'ont pas
d'engagement partisan qui ne sont pas
membres d'un parti politique mais qui
ont été et qui sont toujours présidents
d'associations de colocataires de
locataires pardon présidents
d'associations sportives culturelles des
gens qui animent la ville au quotidien
qui la font déjà vivre qui sont un peu
le coeur battant de la ville de trappes
et qui ont voulu s'impliquer s'engager à
nos côtés donc c'est une fierté d'avoir
autant de deux syndicalistes de
militants
vous le disait d'eux des personnes qui
s'occupent des personnes âgées par
exemple d'autres qui font du soutien
scolaire dans la ville de trappes cc
personne très concrètement engagés pour
la ville qui vivent tous et toutes à
trappes on a une liste 100% trappistes
du maire jusqu'au dernier de liste là où
les adversaires habitent souvent paris
ou des villages du sud yvelines ça nous
distingue de nos concurrents mais c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il est rapide nous font
confiance alors nous allons maintenant
entrés dans le vif du sujet et voir
ensemble plusieurs thèmes de campagne
municipale est tout d'abord celui de
l'éducation vous proposé plusieurs
mesures pour les prochaines rentrées
scolaires mais en priorité vous
souhaitez mettre l'accent sur la culture
à l'école expliquez-nous alors ça c'est
totalement prioritaire pour nous et j'ai
à mes côtés ma première adjointe
sandrine grandes jambes qui est en
charge de la vie scolaire et de l'art et
la vie culturelle pourquoi on a souhaité
lier les deux parce que pour réussir
dans la vie vous comme moi nous avons
besoin d'un bagage et notamment d'un
bagage scolaire et culturel est ce qui
distingue les enfants de trappes
d'enfants qui ont la chance de grandir
dans des baux arrondissement parisien
c'est souvent que nous avons des écoles
qui sont d'un moins bon niveau scolaire
qui sont moins attractives et donc
l'enjeu pour nous c'est de réussir à
faire en sorte que nos écoles soit
meilleur demain qu'ils attirent les
meilleurs enseignants que les élèves de
trappes pour réussir n'est pas à quitter
la ville pour s'inscrire dans d'autres
établissements mais plutôt à s'inscrire
dans nos écoles parce qu'elles sont plus
attractifs qu'ailleurs ça c'est notre
objectif à terme comment on y parvient à
notamment en mettant de la culture dans
l'école de la culture d'ailleurs partout
on veut inonder trappe de culture dans
nos rues dans nos établissements dans
nos cafés et demain évidemment à l'école
nous avons commencé déjà en ouvrant deux
classes à horaires aménagés qui ont
vocation à permettre en plus de
l'enseignement classique les le
programme scolaire qu'il faut remplir
tout au long de l'année de proposer aux
enfants la découverte d'un instrument la
découverte du théâtre une pratique
artistique qui va donner une coloration
particulière à l'enseignement qu'ils
dont il dispose et qui va attirer
également des enseignants qui vont
s'impliquer dans une école durablement
pas en étant de passage sur deux ou
trois ans parce qu'il y aura des classes
à horaires aménagés parce qu'il y aura
une dimension artistique et culturelle
dans le projet de l'école et qui vont
vouloir venir ici apporter leurs
compétences aux enfants de trappes donc
quand vous vous inscrivez vous savez
quand vous faites une école de
journalisme ou quand vous vous inscrivez
a parcouru pour décrocher les meilleures
écoles on regarde ce que vous avez fait
dans votre scolarité 12 et d'où vous
venez alors quand on vient de trappes
parfois c'est perçu comme un handicap
mais si demain on peut dire oui je viens
de trappes medela l'école dès la classe
de cm1 j'ai pu pratiquer le violon ou le
trombone et je suis devenu au bout de
dix ans grâce à l'école au collège grâce
au conservatoire de la ville de trappes
je suis devenu un maître dans
l'utilisation de mon instrument eh bien
on vous regarde différemment j'ai pu
intégrer pourquoi pas une maîtrise ces
éléments là permettent de distinguer
positivement les enfants qui auront
fréquenté les écoles de trappes c'est
pour cette raison que nous voulons
mettre de la culture partout à commencer
par nos écoles vous propose également la
création d'une centrale d'achat afin de
limiter le coût des fournitures pour les
jeunes sera trappistes qu'ils soient
collégiens aussi les lycéens
concrètement comment ça se déroulerait
alors déjà on va fournir dès la
prochaine rentrée scolaire un kit de
fournitures scolaires à tous les enfants
d'école éléments des moteurs du cp au
cm2 ça ça nous semble essentiel c'est
une façon de dire aux parents à côté de
l'état qui vous aide via l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire la ville assure aussi
un certain nombre de prestations pour
accompagner les familles que vous soyez
riche ou pauvre on donne des droits à
tous les enfants ensuite pour le collège
et le lycée qui n'est pas une compétence
de la mairie vous savez que c'est le
département et la région on a eu l'idée
de proposer d'adhérer à une centrale
d'achat groupé plutôt que chaque parent
achète dans les supermarchés du coin
prix au prix maximum vous savez le tarif
classique pour les usagers des
fournitures scolaires et bien au
mutualisera et au lieu d'acheter une
règle je parle qu'est ce qu'on achète
des classeurs des cahiers des feuilles
des stylos des stylos plumes et c'est
plutôt que de les acheter à l'unité on
proposera de pouvoir inscrire les
familles qui le souhaitent mutualiser
groupe et nos achats parce que quand
vous négocier en tant que mary mille
paquets de feuilles double ça vous coûte
moins cher à l'unité que si vous en
achetez deux ou trois donc c'est une
idée toute simple qui coûtera pas grand
chose à l'amérique juste en groupant les
commander en organisant la commande
collective mais qui permettra de
diminuer le tarif pour les familles et
donc d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
familles trappistes qu'elle soit très
modeste ou qu'elles soient issues de
classes moyennes concernant les cours
d'école maintenant vous souhaitez les
végétalisée alors est ce que ça veut
dire que vous voulez supprimer les
terrains de foot pour en faire des
potagers comme les cours de récréation
des genres et bien omar écologistes en
partie il y aura toujours des terrains
de foot de basket de hand de tout ce
qu'on voudra parce que il y en a besoin
et on a la chance d'avoir des cours
d'école qui sont plutôt assez spacieuse
à trappes est aujourd'hui comme dans
beaucoup de villes de france on a du
sang pour sang mitchum vous savez on a
coupé les arbres on a coulis du bitume
est la conséquence concrète c'est que
quand on est en plein en plein mois de
juin en plein mois de mai et qu'il ya
des canicules de plus en plus souvent et
bien les enfants cuisent littéralement
sous le soleil et d'ailleurs il ne
supporte pas de rester très longtemps
exposé au soleil ils ne peuvent même pas
profiter de leurs temps de récréation
donc l'enjeu pour nous c'est de recréer
des îlots de fraîcheur c'est de mettre
des brumisateurs par exemple ramener de
l'eau dans les écoles c'est de replanter
des arbres de casser du bitume et de le
remplacer par du gazon tout simplement
de permettre effectivement aux enfants
ma de gratter la terre de cultiver un
potager et les abords de nos écoles nous
permettent de le faire dès les semaines
qui viennent nous allons installer des
premiers potager dans nos écoles qui
seront animées par un établissement qui
fait travailler des adultes handicapés à
trappes et donc vous aurez des personnes
en situation de handicap qui vont venir
dans nos écoles pour animer avec des
enfants la culture de ces potagers dans
l'école je crois que ce sont des projets
très vertueux parce que ça permet à tous
les enfants même ceux qui habitent ou
11e étage d'une tour hlm de trappes de
pouvoir toucher la terre planter des
tomates cultivées une salade de le faire
en plus accompagnés par des adultes
bienveillant et parfois des adultes
différents il faut accepter que chacun
ait sa place dans nos sociétés ça change
aussi le regard des enfants sur le
handicap que ce soit sur des enfants
handicapés ou des adultes handicapés et
ça nous permet de remettre un peu de vie
et d'humanité de fraîcheur et de verdure
dans nos écoles qui en ont bien besoin
autre thème maintenant passons aux
travaux d'enfouissement de la n10 le
chantier a déjà débuté l'objectif est
d'en fuir la route nationale qui coupe
la ville de trappes en deux un plateau
urbain sera créé ensuite les travaux
devraient durer jusqu'en 2028 le projet
avait initié il ya longtemps par
l'ancien maire guy malandain c'est un
projet d'une grande importance pour
absolument il faut rendre hommage aux
maires successifs y compris guy
malandain qui ont porté ce projet
jouer j'en profite pour rendre hommage à
bernard hugo feu bernard hugo qui est
décédé il ya quelques mois et qui a été
un immense maire de trappes il a été
maire pendant 40 ans et qui a porté ce
projet à bras le corps pendant des
décennies auprès de l'état auprès du
préfet de département pour essayer
d'obtenir un engagement financier de
l'état nous arrivons au bout de ce
combat de mes prédécesseurs c'est un
projet de 100 millions d'euros avec un
financement à 40 millions d'euros de
l'état et puis le département la région
la ville elle-même y contribuent
également saint quentin en yvelines il
participe et donc ce projet il est sous
maîtrise d'oeuvre de l'état c'est une
route nationale comme son nom l'indiqué
c'est l'état qui porte le chantier mais
la ville est très vigilante et je
l'étais comme maire pendant un an à
veiller à ce que les conséquences du
chantier soient les plus faibles
possibles les pionniers des nuisances
notamment aux riverains exactement sur
les riverains vous avez des problèmes de
nuisances sonores bien sûr vous avez des
nuisances liés aux embouteillages qui
sont générés par les travaux il faut
être extrêmement attentif donc j'y serai
je le suis je suis aux côtés des
habitants quand ils se plaignent pour
pouvoir relayer les difficultés surtout
anticiper ces difficultés veillez à ce
que l'état informe bien les habitants
parce que l'état est parfois un peu
laxiste sur l'information on découvre
que les engins arrivent donc nous on
veille à ce que les informations ne
soient
transmises très tôt et qu'elles soient à
leur tour transmises aux habitants on en
a créé pour ça une page spéciale du site
internet est un magazine également que
la ville distribue où elle tient à
informer les riverains de l'avancée du
chantier et donc on est attentif à ce
que ça se passe le mieux possible mais
moi je ne souhaite pas mentir aux
trappistes sur ce chantier il va être
long et il va être douloureux mon
prédécesseur disait souvent que le
chantier aurait s'achèverait en deux à
trois ans on ne fait pas un
enfouissement sur 600 m avec la
construction d'un plateau de 3
millimètres carrés en l'espace de deux à
trois ans c'est pas sérieux ça durera
six sept huit ans il vaut mieux le
savoir pour se préparer à organiser au
mieux sur ce plateau et robin justement
quels sont vos projets qu'est ce que
vous voulez en faire alors je veux que
ce soit un espace vert là encore je ne
souhaite pas j'ai mis un coup d'arrêt au
projet précédent qui était un projet de
bétonner et avec je vous le répète ses
difficultés avec les îlots de chaleur
qui sont créés par le tout béton et
évidemment les périodes caniculaires
étant de plus en plus nombreuses ça
devient une vraie souffrance pour les
riverains donc nous on fera quelque
chose d'écologistes de verre mais en
revanche je ne veux pas décider tout
seul c'est une conception que j'ai de la
démocratie qui consiste à ne pas croire
que parce qu'on est élu on a raison sur
tout et on doit décider tout seul donc
on va donner la parole aux trappistes on
a commencé les idées commencent à
affleurer beaucoup nous demandent des
espaces de jeux pour les enfants des
îlots de fraîcheur pareil vraie place
pour nous pour permettre aux enfants de
se rafraîchir l'été et profiter de cet
espace pour s'égayer d'avoir pourquoi
pas un manège pourquoi pas des marchands
de crêpes etc et donc nous allons
concevoir ce projet avec les habitants
on va lancer une grande concertation des
ateliers de travail et les habitants qui
sont intéressés les riverains mais pas
que on peut habiter à l'autre bout de la
ville et se sentir intéressés pour cette
nouvelle place centrale de la ville de
trappes et nous pourrons travailler avec
eux pour dessiner une place centrale un
centre ville qui permettent de donner la
place à toutes les générations autre
thème que j'aimerais aborder avec vous
c'est l'image de trappe lors de votre
année en tant que maire vous avez été
amené à parler de trappes dans des
médias nationaux la ville a été le
théâtre de nombreuses polémiques
certains l'a désigné comme un
territoires perdus de la république
alors que ferez vous en tant que maire
de trappes pour redorer l'image de la
ville déjà je continuerai à ne pas
laisser dire n'importe quoi sur ma ville
et à défendre l'honneur et la dignité
des trente deux mille habitants qui
vivent rendez vous compte on a dit des
choses absolument inimaginable à
l'époque sur la ville de trappes on a
laissé entendre que tous les habitants
de la ville étaient des terroristes en
puissance vous imaginez 32 mille
terroristes en puissance qu'est ce qu'on
fait et qu'est ce qu'on dit des bébés
qui naissent c'est qu'ils grandissent
dans cette ville et qui sont pas encore
condamnés quoi qu'il arrive ils pourront
maîtriser leur vie et c'est ça le
travail de l'équipe municipale que je
mène cette faire en sorte que tous ces
enfants puissent maîtriser leur vie
saint-céré pleinement dans la république
y trouver leur place et s'épanouir n'est
de bon français savez moi je suis issu
d'une famille immigrée ouvrière modeste
j'ai grandi en hlm et aujourd'hui je
suis maire de la république je porte
jusqu'à récemment je portais les chars
bleu blanc rouge il célébrer les
mariages j'ai un attachement viscéral à
la république française à l'école en
particulier qui m'a permis de me
construire et d'être diplômés à bac +5
et de devenir ce que je suis devenu mais
je souhaite que tous les enfants de
cette ville est la même chance et pour
ça on se bat et on se battra alors moi
je continuerai pied à pied à tenir tête
à ceux qui insultent la ville de trappes
et les trappistes et je considère que
nous n'avons plus à baisser les yeux que
nous devons faire respecter notre
honneur et notre dignité et on
continuera à multiplier les réussites et
aussi à faire parler de ceux qui ont
sonné à trappes ont grandi à trappes et
sont devenus de belles personnes pas
uniquement nos artistes et nos sportifs
qui sont bien connues jamel debbouze
omar sy nicolas anelka au but bien
d'autres mais il faut aussi parler de ce
qu'ils sont devenus médecins qui sont
devenus pompiers ils sont devenus
avocats et qui créent des entreprises
qui créent des emplois dans ce pays qui
cotisent pour les retraites tous ces
beaux profils et toutes ces belles
réussites il faudra les valoriser et ce
sera le travail du maire sur le thème de
la sécurité maintenant au delà de la
troupe propose de rang de réformer la
police municipale parce que selon vous
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il
faut amener à faire eh ben il propose
que nous faisons déjà othman la trouille
autres menaceront c'est le ministère de
la parole savez c'est beaucoup de
critiques beaucoup de paroles en l'air
mais en réalité ne fait que commenter ce
que nous avons déjà engagé concernant la
police municipale c'était dans mon
programme et nous sommes déjà en train
de le réaliser nous sommes en train de
doubler les effectifs de police quand je
suis arrivé il y avait six policiers
municipaux actifs nous avons recruté six
policiers supplémentaires que j'ai
bouclé d'ailleurs cet été juste avant
mon départ ces policiers sont commencent
à arriver un premier d'arriver au mois
de septembre le dernier arrive début
janvier
début janvier nous aurons des brigades
qui circuleront des patrouilles 7 sur 7
samedi et dimanche compris et on en a
besoin qui circuleront le soir et on en
a besoin notamment la nuit quand il ya
un certain nombre de nuisances de gênes
d'actes de délinquance qui sont commis
sur notre ville et malheureusement on ne
peut pas content et je le dis clairement
on ne peut pas compter sur les effectifs
de police nationale qui ne sont pas
assez nombreux on a des policiers qui
font ce qu'ils peuvent quand on appelle
le commissariat ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent mais quand vous avez une
patrouille pour un bassin de 165 mille
habitants à l'échelle de saint quentin
en yvelines ça ne suffit pas pour
répondre aux doléances des trappistes
non nous allons compenser
malheureusement on est aux condamnés à
le faire avec des effectifs de police
municipale et des patrouilles de police
municipale s'est déjà en cours les
recrutements sont bouclés nous allons
continuer à ouvrir des postes dans les
années qui viennent mais dès le mois de
janvier nous patrouillerons 7 sur 7 et
la nuit autres avec ou sans autre magnat
through dernière problématique pour
cette émission celle du logement vous
vous êtes engagé vous en tant que maire
à soutenir fortement les locateurs ou
constater qu'il ya trop d'abus bien sûr
on a une situation aberrante attrapant
nous avons à peu près 60 % de logements
sociaux un petit peu moins ces logements
sociaux sont gérés par quelques
bailleurs notamment deux principaux ses
bailleurs ont tendance à considérer que
c'est un peu la bataille du pot de fer
contre le pot de terre et les locataires
sont démunis puisqu'ils sont
relativement isolées peu outillés
riddick mans administrativement
financièrement pour pouvoir défendre
leurs droits et moi je constate depuis
que je suis élu des abus il y à un
nombre de logements insalubres délirant
sur la ville de trappes il ya des gens
qui paye tous les mois leur loyer et les
charges qui vont avec parfois 1000 euros
voire davantage de loyer pour des
logements sociaux ce qui est absolument
inconcevable et qui pourtant vivent dans
des logements insalubres quand je suis
arrivé il y avait un seul agent
quasiment à la retraite d'ailleurs une
personne qui a 70 ans un seul agent pour
faire des constats d'insalubrité dans le
logement j'ai multiplié par quatre les
effectifs nous avons créé des postes
supplémentaires recrutés une ingénieurs
et de techniciens qui vont faire des
constats d'insalubrité chez les
habitants et qui vont ordonner aux
bailleurs d'effectuer les travaux
d'assainissement nécessaires mais ce
n'est pas tout nous constatons que lie à
des habitants qui paye à un niveau de
charges exorbitants parfois le loyer
doubler à cause uniquement des charges
je paye moins cher dans ma maison en
charge d'électricité et de chauffage que
certains locataires de f3 en zone hlm
c'est absolument inadmissible donc nous
luttons sur deux aspects le premier
c'est contrôler la réalité de ses
charges et l'honnêteté de la facturation
qui est décidée par les bailleurs il
faut contrôler parce qu'il ya parfois
des erreurs de bonne foi il ya parfois
des abus en profitant de la naïveté des
habitants donc nous contrôlons avec un
partenariat que nous avons noué avec une
association qui s'appelle l'adil
l'association pour le droit à
l'information des locataires et qui
vient vérifier avec des juristes
spécialisés si tout est en bon ordre
nous intervenons sur un deuxième champ
qui est plus long mais qui produira des
résultats tangibles c'est que beaucoup
de locataires paient des charges
excessives
tout simplement parce que leur bâtiment
leur logement ne sont pas isolés quand
vous chauffer à fond un bâtiment si vous
chauffez votre logement etc les fenêtres
ouvertes vous allez payer une fortune
est mal chauffés c'est à peu près ce
qu'on vit les murs sont tellement faim
les menuiseries ça les fenêtres sont
tellement poreuses que toute la chaleur
qui est générée par le chauffage que
vous payez en payant votre facture edf
ne sert à rien puisque le logement est
une passoire thermique donc nous
demandons d'ailleurs nous avons mis une
grosse pression depuis un an au bailleur
d'investir massivement de faire du
rattrapage pour isoler convenablement
ces logements et permettent que le
chauffage les charges payées par les
locataires diminue eh bien nous avons
déjà obtenu l'engagement de plusieurs
bailleurs sur plusieurs quartiers le
quartier jean macé l'allée des yvelines
la rue louise-michel castiglione del
lago les trappistes qui nous écoutent
reconnaîtront et on a dans les années
qui viennent plus de 6 millions d'euros
qui seront investis pour la rénovation
thermique par deux bailleurs principaux
merci beaucoup à lire abed est revenu
dans l'hebdo polisy sur radio sensations
je rappelle que vous êtes candidat à la
mairie de rappeler le premier tour aura
lieu le 10 octobre prochain mais nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de l'hebdo politiques
m'ont invité sera alors othman nasrullah
tête de liste d'engagements trappe
citoyens très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
les politiques